it's been a an ongoing procedure here in
Florida because the the laws have been
slow to change now they just finally the
legislation just passed where we can now
have up to 2 ounces of cannabis in your
possession and actually be able to smoke
the flower now which for patients is
gonna be huge in the state of Florida
where and where is this this is here in
the state of Florida in Florence though
right correct it's just for just for
patients right now right now we're
probably looking at the recreational
aspect of it coming up soon a couple
different things can happen
the president could go ahead and wave
his magic wand for re-election purposes
and go ahead and legalize it the
governor nationwide nationwide right
that would help him get elected again
absolutely yeah it's ridiculous we have
14 states right now that have it
legalized in some way recreational or
medical right when you look at some of
the dynamics and you start doing the
math I initially get getting into this
one of the bigger bigger picture of the
economics that are involved so I go to
one of the first areas that ever started
being sold recreationally which was
Denver Colorado right and it was amazing
when you look at this this Denver small
city kind of a microcosm of five million
people there tourism was around 27,000
people a year on average after Cam's
became legal that went to 77,000 the to
date now I went out there and I spoke to
chief brown with your aura Police
Department Aurora Police Department's
the largest Police Department in Denver
so I went there and actually spoke to
him and asked him about is there any
positive that's coming out of this and
he refused to really wave the flag on
the positive side he said listen the
people here have voted on this I'm here
to support what the people wanted but I
will tell you this we have 28 new cars
patrol cars that we didn't have before
we have three new high schools that are
going up now the teachers have gotten
the pay they deserve the economy just in
this one microcosm from 2014 to current
it is about 1.5 billion dollars just to
that area alone so when you start to
look at the infrastructure and what's
really taking place it's a dynamic it's
it's a change in entrepreneurship at the
change in with the way we look at
certain ways to relax and enjoy our so
when I looked at the bigger picture they
had they had obviously was 420 was
coming up and the chief said well if
you're staying here for 420 I suggest
you go out he put me out with one of his
sergeants and I met him the next day
this is in Denver this is in Denver okay
and the funny part was that when I got
there to help him what kind of unload he
said hey do me a favor grab that big box
of Doritos right there I just laughed I
said you're kidding right he's like no
dude really who doesn't want to smoke a
joint need a bag of Doritos
sure and I said Sarge we need to have a
talk I really need to understand where
you're coming from he said this is
really didn't good for the economy here
maybe what you're gonna see this
afternoon is the how the big smoke out
here and he goes if you look around
there's probably about almost a hundred
new restaurants that have popped up in
the area now that we're not here anymore
so one of those restaurants mean to the
city it's more tax income for us it's
more revenue we generate it more I'm
listen he said well-fed people are happy
people and I said now let me ask you
swith this event going on out here today
what is what is the arrest record I mean
he goes to listen
typically this was a political event he
says we have 5,000 people out here it'd
be crazy I'd have to have all my
officers out here people getting violent
right yeah but absolutely everybody
wants everybody has a stand okay and so
he said I'd have to have the Sheriff's
Department out here we'd have to have a
paddy wagon set up I've got to make sure
there's room at the jail so I said so
you're probably talking you know a
hundred plus officers deputies he said
oh absolutely so look at all the
overtime that's incurred look at all the
time the space that's taken up in jail
all of these different things are
defined by what we do and I said so let
me ask you this with this taking place
today how many arrests were you go on
you guys listen other than the drunks
there'll be no arrests today Wow so
again these were all eye-opening
experiences for me looking at the bigger
picture not really ever thinking it from
a medical perspective but truly seeing
now the benefits I'm talking to law
enforcement who have a much greater
detail of understanding the THC and when
I talk to these law enforcement officers
across the board the funny part is they
always started out by saying hey look no
one smokes a joint that tax my deputies
or a tax an officer or or beats his wife
up right so it's a it's from an
educational perspective it's been really
really interesting to say the least